[Music]
iron man behind you are you a nerd by
any chance
uh sir it takes one to no one
[Laughter]
most people don't know what cyberdyne is
only yeah
yeah i guess
yeah right exactly although some people
in hospitality were like are you wearing
a terminator t-shirt i'm like oh at
least you know the move anyway
so i spoke to you earlier this year and
i've spoken to you a number of times
over the years and i tried to come up
with a whole bunch of new questions
today let's see how this effing goes
okay
what what is the difference between
making something in america versus the
united kingdom
well it's a shorter commute uh if i make
it in the united kingdom obviously
because i live there um
i don't know i i think the
it's interesting with with something
like this luck because i'm i'm sort of
doing both i'm i'm based in the uk and
this was because of the pandemic as much
as anything else
i'm in a little studio that's that's
been set up at my home but i'm talking
to los angeles and peggy holmes who's
directing me from there so i'm kind of
it's a bit of a hands across the ocean
moment there and in that regard making
an animation in the us or the uk is is
exactly the same there's there's very
little difference whatsoever um and
similarly
in
live action terms
you know the process doesn't you know
what changes is the terms like in in
america they say last looks
in the uk they say final checks just
before you shoot and makeup and hair
come in and what have you
um and there's a couple craft services
is better in the u.s that's for sure
i was literally gonna say i've been on
sets in both and the number one
difference is craft service yeah in the
in the uk about 4 p.m you get some moldy
sandwiches and that's it
you know the the funny thing is you're
not exaggerating it's really
it's really that dramatic um
you've gotten to do a lot of cool things
because of who you are
rank how high on the list was going
backstage with your daughter to meet bts
that was up there
that was seriously up there i mean i i'd
become a sort of bts fan via
um
via her she'd sort of introduced me to
them
and um i had become like we watched a
lot of them on youtube so by the time we
went to see them in las vegas i kind of
was like genuinely a fan
and so meeting them was just
surreal because we walked into a room
and they were just stood there
just waiting for us to walk in and they
were absolutely lovely and um it was
extraordinary and i i was a little
starstruck were they sure to like they
do this with a lot of people do they
have any idea they've seen sean of the
dead do you know what i mean well rm who
is the the probably the most um adept
english speaker of the group although
they're all sort of like you know
getting better at speaking english um
he's a bit of a movie fan and and he'd
gone to see baby driver with v another
one in the band um so he was aware of of
my work for sure and we had a little
chat about movies and stuff
i didn't know if if the other guys had
seen sean of the dead or anything like
that i mean i presume they have um
but they were just really lovely it was
a nice moment if you could get the
financing to make anything you want uh
what would you make and why is there
something that's been like kicking
around in your brain oh my god yeah
loads of things i mean
and it probably wouldn't be something
vast and big it would just be the chance
to make
i have a couple of things that i'm
developing
um right now which are so i won't sort
of talk about them specifically but um
getting them made would be really fun
without the sort of
the haggle and wrangle of trying to get
people to sort of like have faith in an
original idea these days you know that's
kind of difficult um
if you just had unlimited resources you
could
you know you could make the kind of
stuff the kind of stuff i miss seeing at
the cinema really
i put on twitter that i was going to
talk to you i had a few people ask
questions but i'm going to ask the one
from someone named nick and he asked me
to ask is there ever going to be a third
season of space
that would be nick frost
i think you think i'm joking he really
put this on there oh i know i know
because he knows that question rankles
me uh tell him that we made it we just
didn't cast him in it
um you know i love the show and i'm
actually gonna be serious about this
is i think that what like when you look
at top gun maverick and
the use of time between the original and
now it made the movie and so many people
are making things where they're using
the real
time to continue telling a story is
there actually any real interest in your
brain like would i want to revisit these
characters you know 30 years later and
see what they're doing or it's really
like you're so tired of this question
i think the great thing about top gun
maverick was that they made it about
you know it wasn't just about continuing
the story there was a there was a
relevance to
what has happened in the world since and
also a kind of strange parallel between
maverick and tom being these kind of
emissaries from an almost forgotten era
of something you know
like maverick is the last
sort of fighter pilot and tom is the
last movie star and there was a real
sort of
there was just a really beautiful timing
of all that kind of stuff i'm not sure
what would be the value of seeing tim
and daisy beyond that moment in their
lives because spaced was all about that
moment specifically it wasn't about
those characters as much as it was about
what it was like to be in your 20s at
the turn of the century
at the very beginning of the kind of the
age of the geek you know when when we
were just realizing that we could
actually spend some of our adulthood
uh participating in the things that we
enjoyed as kids you know that was the
the beginnings of that era which is now
the norm
so um i'm not sure
i don't i don't think if i want to see
them again really
sure uh it is interesting because you
and i are old enough to know when you
look back at that era it was just such a
different world for geeks and nerds it
was just not you know what i mean it was
it's like a 180. um yeah absolutely yeah
um if you you've made a lot of projects
is there one
on your resume that you think like
deserves more people checking out
because you're really proud of it and
maybe it just didn't get seen by enough
people
yeah a couple of them actually i
i did a film called hector in the search
for happiness which is a sort of um kind
of fabalistic travelogue about a i mean
really it was about a kind of
middle-aged white guy who isn't happy so
i can understand why people were like
yeah what's his problem but um it was a
really amazing film to make it was a lot
of fun it's a very beautiful film the
message of it is lovely um
so and i and what's nice is that anyone
who does see it tends to sort of like be
very effusive about
about what it means to them which is
nice i did a anything when you do small
movies
you kind of want them to be seen by the
the same people the same amount of
people that watch the big movies and so
i've done little indie films
i feel like like lost transmissions or
something that you you you hoped would
have reached a larger audience but the
fact is
you know the more sort of specific and
uh serious you get often
you know the appeal becomes more focused
and and
those films will never exist on the
scale of you know the kind of pure
entertainment movies
uh
when was the last time you re-watched
something
the way you did it back when you were a
teenager in your 20s the way you would
revisit empire strikes back again and
again have you done that with a tv show
or a movie since your 20s
weirdly enough i watched on the flight
over to new york i watched blade runner
2049 again
um
because i really really like that film i
i feel like
it's a little too long
um i don't blame denny villner for
loving the world so much she wanted to
sort of stay and stay in it for a little
longer than two hours but i think as a
sequel it's um
it's a really brilliant evolution of the
first film you know the idea taking the
idea of the first film and evolving
those ideas and i i
i like re-watching that film i've
watched
a lot of films recently again because my
i have a teenage daughter and
we spend a lot of our times watching a
lot of our time watching movies together
she's a big horror buff so i've gone
back and um shown her horror movies that
i loved as a kid
and
it's been really educational doing that
like watching a film like
reanimator
which i remember as being uproariously
funny and kind of you know super kind of
cool when i was 16 and then watching it
with a teenage girl who's like dad
why is she naked why why is there this
scene when this woman is being abused by
a severed head how is that entertaining
and i'm i'm going oh yeah
we have come on a little bit since then
and um but at the same time you know she
loves her favorite film is is the
shining you know she really really digs
that so that's really fun to
to see that again through the eyes of a
child or the best thing was
terminator showing her she knew nothing
about terminator showing her the first
one
and then showing her the second one with
her not knowing the twist which we all
did going into when we saw her
and her saying to me in the early stages
he's a bit different in this dad he's
kind of he's not as mean and like
like she [ __ ] called it you know that
was kind of insane jumping into why i
actually get to talk to you what are you
most excited about for audiences to see
in luck
i think luck i mean it's just an
incredibly realized world that they've
built you know in terms of the the luck
dimension where where good luck and bad
luck get made it it's such a triumph of
animation it's so beautifully intricate
and the way that it moves and the way
good luck and bad luck are different um
all that as a spectacle is wonderful but
i think at the heart of it is this
really lovely message about
you know how we create our own luck and
how
good things happen to you when you start
behaving like a good person i think i
think it's full of
as the best animations are
full of
messages which appeal to both you know
young and old people alike and um it was
a really fun
uh record to do you know i think it's a
it's a really beautiful movie and a
great sort of kickoff for sky dance
animation what was it like actually
developing another scottish accent that
was not scotty
well i have one scottish accent so
really i just did that one i i kind of i
kind of got because because i because my
wife is glaswegian
my scottish accent generally hovers
around the sort of west coast of
scotland the sort of southwest midwest
coast i guess of scotland and i didn't
really want to sort of deviate now that
i'm good at it i didn't want to deviate
into other areas of school i mean
because it gets quite different in the
east and up north
so really it's a similar similar voice
but the interesting thing about bob is
that
he's not entirely what he seems
and um that was a fun part of him to
play that he's also carrying quite a
dark secret with him animated projects
often go through like a lot of radical
changes um and so how did luck change as
you were recording or was it pretty much
like the whole like what the final
product was ultimately what you started
with
well the great thing about animation is
that you can sort of forensically
construct it um as you go and you know
you do a bit of voice and then as soon
as the animators get the voice they are
able to sort of start constructing the
film the director peggy holmes in this
case was able to as as every animation
director gets to do is is pick each line
reading and compile the entire vocal uh
track of the
um of the the film really carefully as
you do that
things come up and you think oh hang on
that idea
would work better if we did this here
and you are able to make those changes
as you go so though the film was pretty
much
you know what it was when we started
there were lots of little details which
were able to be adjusted and finessed
and nuanced as we as we went along which
is uh it's exciting how long did you
know that the mission impossible titles
were going to be dead reckoning
do you know what i found out on the day
of the trailer and not from chris
macquarie i found out from the trailer
so i immediately
no no one told me so i i texted i texted
mchugh and was like
dead reckoning were you gonna tell us
that at some point
um i i heard it was gonna be something
else but um but i i like that i like
that because it reminds me of what
land of the dead was originally called
dead reckoning so finally i get to be in
a film called dead reckoning when you
heard the title did it make sense to you
with what the story is but you know what
i mean
oh 100 yeah absolutely
uh i know you're not going to uh say too
much but where are you in the filming of
mi 8 right now we've just started so
we're right back to the beginning again
there's still a couple of things to pick
up with seven because
i think the way eight evolves might sort
of like determine a few things which is
a great sort of
luxury we have in this situation being
able to do two films back to back um but
yeah we are we are now in
officially in production of of uh dead
reckoning part two cannot effing wait
listen man always great to talk with you
wish you nothing but the best you know
have a great day man thank you nice to
see you